-Our first guest tonight is an
Academy Award-nominated actres
you know from her work in film
such as "An Education,"
"The Great Gatsby,"
and "Mudbound."
She is both
an executive producer
and the star of
"Promising Young Woman,
which is in theaters now
and on demand this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-I just thought that you were --
-Drunk?
-Yeah.
-Really drunk?
-[Bleep], yeah.
-Well, I'm not.
But that's good, isn't it?
-i think you should leave.
-Oh.
Now you want me to leave?
-No.
I just -- I'm really high.
Like, I'm really [Bleep] hig
right now.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I think you should go.
-But a second ago, you wer
determined for me to stay.
You were pretty insistent,
actually.
-I'm a nice guy.
-Are you?
-Please welcome back to
the show Carey Mulligan.
How are you, Carey?
-I'm good, thanks.
How are you?
-I'm good.
This movie -- that clip
really gets across.
This movie has
an excellent score.
It's one of the many thing
I loved about it.
Very dramatic.
A lot of scenes
with great tension.
Are you happy with
how this film turned out?
-Yeah. I mean, I'm so --
I'm so proud
just to have been in it,
to get to witness
what Emerald Fennell,
our director, has done.
She's just a genius -- a sort of
mad genius, but a genius.
-It seems like she knew exactl
the movie she wanted to make
You were obviously involve
early as an executive producer
Were there a lot of
conversations about tone,
or did she know exactly the wa
she wanted to present it
from the beginning?
-I think it was --
I think the film
was in her head.
I think she had -- I mean,
when I signed on to the film
in the same moment that sh
sent me the script,
she also sent me a playlist,
and on that playlist was
Paris Hilton's "Stars are Blind"
and Britney Spears' "Toxic,"
twice.
And you know, but, like, there
was so much of the film --
the wit of the film
was in the music choices
and the production design
and the costume,
and all of that was stuff
that she presented
along with the script.
So it was very much she wa
the captain of the ship
and we were along for the ride
-I've long been a fan
of Britney Spears' "Toxic.
I will admit
to not being as familiar
with Paris Hilton's
work as a singer.
-Really?
-Yeah, I will admit it.
But there's
a wonderful sort of --
I guess you guys are in sort o
a pharmacy karaoke scene
with you and Bo Burnham.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Are you an actual karaoke fan
Because you were very good
in that scene.
-I've done --
Yeah, I do a very good
"(Everything I Do)
I Do It For You."
Yeah, that's my sort of go-to.
And Meat Loaf.
A little bit of Meat Loaf
on a special occasion.
-I like it.
If you go --
That's the thing about karaoke
If you're gonna get your sho
and then wait
for everybody else,
you got to do one of those
eight-minute Meat Loaf songs
just get your time up onstage.
-You've got to do the duet
Play the woman, the dude,
you know, really get into it
-i mean, that really
speaks to ego
that you won't let someone els
come out with you
and split the parts up.
[ Chuckles ]
-No. The only one I ever do.
Those two are my numbers.
-Yeah, I agree.
I think people should drill down
on one or two they're good at.
Nobody wants to see somebody d
a giant catalog of songs.
I want to be careful talking
too much about this film,
because I would hate
to give it away,
because for as much as it seem
like it was in such safe hands
insofar as what it
was trying to do,
there were so many turns that
did not see coming at all.
And there were times
where I thought, "Oh,
this would be a film
that would be a great experience
to see in a theater
with other people
having these same realizations
at the same time.
Do you think that, ever?
-Yeah.
I mean, we were lucky enough
that we had that.
We had a sort of first screening
at Sundance,
and we got to sort of sit
amongst an audience and feel..
You know, I'm so used
to being in sort of dramas
where the best you can hope fo
is a pin-drop silence.
You just want --
you want nothing.
And with
"Promising Young Woman,"
we were getting gasps
and we were getting laughter
and we were getting people
like, yelling.
And it was so exciting.
So, it's definitely a sham
that more people won't see i
in the cinema,
but I think it's also
one of those great things
about independent film,
when it gets --
sort of when people
take notice of it,
then we get
such a bigger audience,
and maybe more people
will watch it at home.
So who knows?
-Is it true
that there was a fight,
an actual fight, broke out
at one of
the Sundance screenings?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
It was actually --
I wasn't there.
It was in L.A., but it was
off a screening
showing Focus, the distributors,
the movie finished.
And there was a test,
an audience there,
to sort of give it an audience
And Emerald was sitting
with all of the executives
around her,
our director, and, yeah,
a fight broke out
between two audience members
who were disagreeing
about what was happening
in the film.
And one was saying sort of
"No, no, stop, stop, stop.
And the other person was saying,
"Look,
If you don't like it,
just get out!"
And this whole thing
kind of broke out.
And Emerald was sort of
creeping, melting into her seat.
But, luckily, I missed it.
-Those were simpler times,
when we fought over
what was happening in movies
[ Chuckling ] I miss those days.
-I miss that, too.
-Last we talked,
you were telling us
how you guys live on a far
that is often muddy,
often a little wet.
I think that one thing
people have had to deal with
as they do more and more
from home is slow Wi-Fi.
How is the farm's Wi-Fi?
Because you're coming across
crystal clear for us now.
-It's taken a lot of work.
It's been my main project
for 2020,
because I had
nothing else to do,
so I focused on
Wi-Fi troubleshooting.
It's pretty sad
that it's the only thing
I've taken away from that year
but I feel like
I put my all into it,
so I'm pretty proud of myself.
-Well, for those of us
with talk shows
who enjoy having you on
as a guest,
I want to say,
on behalf of all of us,
thank you
for upgrading your Wi-Fi.
Congrats on the film.
It is really something special
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.